last week Duchess of York Sarah Ferguson
visited the Big Apple and showed off her
14 pound weight loss hopefully this will
not interfere with their official duties
of sitting on her fat ass all day long
Jesus grace this tape is making my nuts
rub together it's gonna start a fire I'm
sorry that I'm fat
[Music]
I don't like when people think they feel
in times you like yeah you know I'm like
haha it's under my control you know it's
not like weather where I'm like all
these fad pellets are raining down on me
like it just happens you know then
sometimes when I'm eating and I feel
feelings I'll be like nope I'll just
bury those under this this is true every
time I go out to eat with somebody at
least one person will be like hey man
why are you sweating like what's up with
that you know we're not racing I'm like
we're not I thought we were raising the
biggest boost of my day I think is when
I eat myself out of breath I don't know
if you ever done that before it's fun
when you're eating and you go oh and
then you have this you have a chance to
think about it you're like why did I
just stopped to take a deep breath oh
yeah my body also needs air you fat
[ __ ] turd
this week in Minneapolis the Minnesota
obesity center officially opened its
goals to find ways to identify behaviors
that lead to obesity also it's a good
place to meet fat chicks sorry I farted
she went suffers of obesity
I went do you mean fat people she would
know because obesity is well she
actually went no because she was eating
he went good
no just you know between snacks
right and uh she went obesity is a
disease no it's not is it you just like
eating don't you know is know is a how
is that disease oh [ __ ] oh well I said
what's the disease she went everything
tastes good
[Applause]
everything yeah not salads yeah it's not
a disease is it leprosy is a disease
can you imagine Jesus in the temple
people shuffling up to him badges going
Jesus my face is falling off I can't
stop now is a fat chick on a third pie
people said they make excuses don't like
fat people they say it's glandular it's
not glandular it's greed okay it's big
bones yeah big bones covered in meat and
gravy they complain and it's their own
fault
and our own being fat no oh look I'm
getting fat oh oh aeroplane seats
they're not big enough for someone like
me no they're not because if they were
we'd only get 12 [ __ ] people on the
plane it's not fair it is fair that's
what does it and if we're talking about
fairness and aeroplanes why is it I get
the same luggage allowance as a guy
who's 400 pounds
we're both without to carry on 32
kilograms to the plane
I don't know it used up is 32 kilograms
on his tits oh look at that it's like an
ad for a [ __ ] weight loss center
before and way before breaking balls
yeah what I said thongs they're like an
ad for weight loss and in California
Christian Brando was released from state
prison Monday after serving nearly five
years for killing his sister's boyfriend
meanwhile his father Marlon Brando ate
nine pizzas
I think it's time for you to start to
seriously consider salads whatever me
try me let me get off my car before you
flip it over you fat [ __ ] a lot of
streams of math so a lot has changed one
thing's for sure I'm still the fluffy
guy
and I say blow because that is the
politically correct term for those of
you that don't remember I used to say
that there were five levels of madness
reason why I say used to say is because
now there are six I'm at the new one in
Las Cruces the original five levels are
big healthy husky fluffy and dirt people
ask what could be bigger than diet the
new levels called oh hell no
[Applause]
what's the difference you're still
willing to work with level five example
if you're on an elevator and you're with
your friend and this really big guy gets
on and you and your friend look at each
other and you're like deal but you still
let the big guy ride your elevator
that's the difference level six you see
walking towards your elevator that's the
difference the guy that I met was six
foot eight six hundred and fourteen
pounds and he was offended at my show
not by anything that I said but because
of the fact that now at the shows I
started selling t-shirts and apparently
I didn't have his size keep in mind I go
all the way up to 5x on the t-shirts and
he was like you don't have my size I was
like dude I didn't know they made you
I have up to 5x I don't have a picture
of a dinosaur on the back of the tagging
up
yeah Ricki Lake you know she is really
is an animal lover though she has three
cats two dogs and a big ass that follows
her around everywhere
[Applause]
listen I can't stay long I'm in-between
meals so bear with family let me move
that so you can see me yeah I live out
in California where they're only three
fat people they have us on eight-hour
shifts so it works on it
I tried to get in that California living
I tried the beach life every time I'd
lay down people would push me back into
the water hurry up he's dying
that was hard pulling six times and the
bums down at the beach always coming up
to me hey buddy could you help me out on
the sandwich well sure where is it
what originally brought me out there
were the Olympics I don't know if you
recognize me hula hoop contest tried all
the events tried the pole vault drove
that sucker right in the ground I did a
good thing though I straighten up those
uneven parallel bars broad jump killed
her sorry I'm sweating but if I don't
I'll explode every night I gotta watch
that idiot on the news or they're doing
stories about how fat kids again you see
that every night every night they're
talking about kids obese now not fat
kids not shall be the old beasts like
bedridden like just laying there like I
had my first heart attack when I was
four I was riding on my big wheel I
couldn't feel my left side I began to I
began to pass out my head no I don't to
be a dick but how do you get that fat
that quick
I can see you 30 40 years old you went
to McDonald's for 20 years she got a
little gut going put you 5 years old
there's no excuse for that [ __ ] I'm
telling you man that's the parents fault
you know stop feeding them
he doesn't have any money seriously
you can't go get a job so we can go buy
more food he's got to eat whatever you
give them just put a plate of seaweed
right in front of him go ahead eat it I
don't want to eat it good go to bed post
your options I own you until you're 18
do some jumping jacks somebody's parents
are ridiculous they act like they have
no control - like what - I mean I try to
make them eat a salad
it was like no I want a cupcake I said
you can't have it but then he sat on my
chest
and I couldn't breathe that I just I
just wanted to get out fast to a while
people you need tough love at that
moment if your kid is obese and he's
still asking for cake you got to be like
no you little [ __ ] you're eating carrots
and celery until I can pick you up again
this is ridiculous you got a goddamn
hernia on your birthday I look I know
that seems harsh to be making fun of
obese kids I'll tell you why I'm doing
it they don't really exist at least to
the level that they're saying they're
saying it's an epidemic
you know which means when I leave the
theater tonight I should have like
difficulty getting to my car because of
all these fat [ __ ] kids out there
like Jesus Christ they're everywhere
[Music]
but when a willing victim who's
committed no treachery is purer than the
traitor stairs stop
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]